foreign
really this got put together
Rampage was the only originally because
originally was supposed to be Theo and
Joey Diaz in Rampage and then
was it a day ago oh I'm sorry remember
this is in reference to remember when
Theo Vaughn was on Portnoy show singer
I'm doing that show man I don't even
know I'm doing that show okay well this
is this is a companion piece if you will
this got put together
Rampage was the only originally because
originally was supposed to be Theo and
Joey Diaz in Rampage and then
was it a day ago Theo said he was like
it's gonna be tough but put me on the
flyer promote me like a busy day we're
doing rough and rowdy here doing the the
stream with right I think so
I've seen your face in the flyer so he's
probably doing it I don't know he gave
me thinking about it oh he's like uh the
number's not right what's going on are
you doing the stream no I don't know I
didn't make that deal I don't know so
Brennan has already shown like yeah no
fuel City's all in and feels like I
don't know what's going on
I just got put on the flyer I guess said
he was actually tough but put me on the
flyer promote me I should be able to
make it and then yesterday was like I
can't do it and then that's when I hit
up everybody
I I know to be fair he was like I'm down
to do I'd love to do it he's like I
don't know if I'm in town but put me on
the flyer I should be able to do it no
no he's lying
wow I don't know
I just got put on the flyer I guess
um
it's your face who are the other two
faces on that flyer do you know the
flyer I'm talking about it's Joey Diaz
but he got replaced
Kentucky
yeah it's Theo is Theo's face still on
the flyer yeah all right so we know the
rest of this but this is pretty much oh
wait wait plastered all over the fire
yep oh my God his face is was they've
already passed but his face was still on
the flyer
it's amazing by the way that's the
picture of theovania used when his hair
was like that that's weird right
um and then this is good
Tom about you're gonna like this so in
this video Brendan Shaw calls out all of
the haters hiding behind cat profiles
hashtag homeless cats roll the footage
for Mike Jackson who's reporter one foot
in one foot out compared to Jay could be
just your normal time
so he's talking about the Jake Shields
versus Mike Jackson thing that happened
oh okay yeah so I wanted some insight on
this you know this is great that we got
Brendan for this but I will say this for
it's so easy to talk [ __ ] somebody
behind a uh you know a cat profile or
meme or whatever the hell he's he's
going full Jordan Peterson no no anons
yep no Anonymous troll demons he's
attached to it because you know there's
no consequences so what I respect out of
Mike Jackson is again I don't know all
the details so many people like dude
you're wrong they surrounding each other
but for him talk [ __ ] and then actually
try to back it up
which he didn't try to back it up he got
his ass whooped he got his ass whooped
from my understanding Jake Shields right
up and slapped him in the mouth
and and then and then you could just go
over me
so why does he always get everything
wrong well he's stupid I mean you have
to remember he's he's he's he's deeply
even stupid people get some things right
sometimes
I mean I mean he's an anomaly I don't
know what to tell you he's a scientific
anomaly we have to this guy always loses
did you ever see that [ __ ] movie pure
luck with Martin Short it was Martin
Short and uh Danny Glover
I don't think so okay anyway the whole
plot of the movie was which is typical
in late 80s comedy movie but Martin
Short always had bad luck right and the
whole stupid gimmick was uh some like
dignitary's daughter always had bad luck
so he teamed them up with with uh Danny
Glover and it was just everything he did
was he we everything he did was just Mr
Magoo but instead of surviving was
horrible that's who he is that's who he
is he's somebody who everything he does
he does wrong everything he says he says
backwards he marched into tigerbellies
basically accusing [ __ ] accusing them
of of doing some sort of Cyber attack on
him yeah dude you're wrong this random
each other but for him talk [ __ ] and
then actually try to back it up
respect he didn't try to back it up no
he got rolled up on he didn't roll up on
Jake Shields yeah Jake Shields rolled up
on him
respect no one ever do most of them
99.999 these haters would never say that
there's a broken clock but only the hour
hand moves nice never right by the way
99 of these haters want to say anything
in your face I would say to your face
and you would hit me and then I'd sue
you and it'll be hilarious
that's the thing shop doesn't understand
yes you're right there's consequences to
stuff we agree with that but there's
also consequences to the consequences
right like that's how it works you could
hit me and then I realized how much
money does shop have let's go to
Discovery and find out why don't we do
that I don't care
I've been hit bud
I respect my guy has some balls because
if he had balls he wouldn't have said
yeah
please
just slapping him [ __ ] call me call
me or not tell me not call me or Nazi
again
I'm a better fighter in every category
every facet of this fight game Jake
Shields is you know Hall of Famer I
guaran damn teeth that Baba's block list
on Instagram is longer than his
followers list you know it's so funny
knowing that Brendan chop learned the
word facet like within the last 18
months
oh yeah it's pretty funny energy or the
very short run of okay Boomer and what's
up with that he didn't learn fasted he
just misheard someone calling him some
other f word
[Laughter]
he called me a [ __ ] facet I don't
know what that is
Paul he always has when he speaks oh
wait that's the c-clap evolving into
full squeeze mode and you wouldn't be
throwing up that hand sign in front of
others in the streets of LA either would
you be so let me get this 89 of haters
won't say it to your face Shaw Schwab by
the way this said that this is a tfatk
he actually got that name
uh yeah this guy uh I like this is one
of the first ones I really like the
comments because he's funny yeah so says
the guy who doesn't even know when
someone's [ __ ] on him to his face
I.E Tom Segura Rick Glassman every
single time I see a shop show clip I'm
reminded he does a solo podcast and
never ceases to blow my mind and I'm
definitely changing my profile to a cat
but I will say this for it's so easy to
talk [ __ ] somebody behind a you know cat
profile or meme or whatever the hell you
are
you're so stupid Brendan it astonishes
me every time how dumb you are
it's and how not just Dom but how he
walks into being wrong about every he
reads every situation totally wrong yeah
he's always wrong it's it's it's it I
don't know how he does it um